oui laurence pour l'anniversaire donc le
terrible anniversaire de cette
catastrophe écologique de l'erika
c'était il ya un an exactement le 12
décembre 99 le pétrolier maltais là-bas
dans l'océan s'est cassé en deux et
souillait plus de 400 kilomètres de
côtes avec un coût total pour cette
catastrophe
depuis le 3 milliards de francs alors
évidemment l'époque catastrophe pour la
pêche catastrophe pour le tourisme
catastrophe pour les huîtres aussi et
pour les coqs
tout ça est rentré dans l'ordre
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on s'est beaucoup inquiété
alors les coques justement tintin est
très très content de venir dans la
région
le petit garçon pourquoi parce que le
croisic est le premier producteur de
coqs en france c'est coke en stock
tous nous tout près d'ici du côté de
gerrans si professionnellement tout est
rentré dans l'ordre
il faut manger des huîtres il faut
manger des coques elles sont très bonnes
aujourd'hui en revanche c'est vrai que
le traumatisme a été marqué pendant très
très longtemps reportage de jacques
devaux et michel hiver à quelques jours
des fêtes de noël
l'activité bat son plein dans le trait
du faso premières zones d'élevage de
coqs en france on pascal chaullet comme
pour ses confrères le naufrage de
l'erika n'est plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir
et pourtant la pêche ici a été interdite
pendant cinq mois et narry ouvert que le
13 juin dernier le consommateur par
contre n'auraient pas compris que ainsi
toucher ne soit pas marqué par une
fermeture
donc je crois que la fermeture était un
mal nécessaire il ya d'ailleurs eu
aucune protestation du milieu
professionnel en avril dernier pour en
finir avec la pollution les
professionnels du secteur n'avait pas
ménagé leurs efforts
prenant même la pelle pour nettoyer
l'entrée du très du croisic ou une nappe
de pétrole polluer l'eau de mer en étant
on va dominer le nettoyage on va avancer
de 20 mètres par jour et puis petit à
petit on l'aura aujourd'hui les machines
à récolter les coques ont remplacé les
pelleteuses mais les 16 entreprises du
secteur ont subi un préjudice de 8
millions de francs pendant toute la
fermeture pascal chollet a perdu entre
deux et trois cent mille
par mois une perte prise en charge par
la collectivité les entreprises ont tout
de suite été alimentée globalement par
des avances trésorerie qui couvrait une
grande partie du préjudice
donc maintenant on attend on attend que
le fipol paye pour pouvoir rembourser
les prêteurs que sont le département et
la région
et si le fipol ne paye pas tout le
préjudice l'état s'est engagé à verser
la différence
mais si professionnellement les traces
du naufrage ont été effacés pascal
chaullet conserve une grande rancoeur
envers total
je suis professionnel mais je suis
contribuable et le contribuable est
révolté parce que ça nous coûte cher et
j'ai l'impression que le coupable se
découpe pas cher ce qui fait que j'ai
peur qu'on n'ait pas fait grand chose
pour éviter la suivante aujourd'hui
parce qu'à se tourner vers l'avenir l'an
prochain il va investir dans une
nouvelle machine à récolter des coques
erika n'aura pas tuer la profession